you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video one
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and we're going to have a look
at the most basic checkmate the one
where it is our king and queen versus
the enemy king now one of the first
things to know is that when we're
working with just our king and queen
versus the enemy king the only way to
give checkmate is if the enemy king is
on the edge of the chessboard so I'm
referring here to this a file h-file
rank one or rank eight he needs to be
located somewhere here in order to give
checkmate so let's see what approach we
can take in order to force the enemy
king to the edge now a good start here
is to simply identify which edge of the
board we would like the enemy came to go
to and I'm going to pick this one here
this eighth rank I'm going to force the
enemy King there and a good first move
is a queen move we're going to look to
position our queen in a way so that she
restricts the enemy king now a good
start is Queen d4 she's restricting the
king she's cutting the King off not
allowing him to cross this fourth rank
not allowing him to move away from the
eighth rank another good start would
have been Queen to a4 doing similar
however if we could be a bit more
essential with our queen this is often
all the better because she is
restricting the king that much more
taking some more squares away from the
king so once we've done that once we've
positioned our Queens so that she cuts
the king of we look to now improve our
King position it takes a team effort in
order to give checkmate so we need to
work with our king and queen to give
checkmate here so what we look to do is
basically move our King as close to the
enemy King as we can and this right here
this position is generally what we're
looking for in this approach that I'm
showing here in this method that I'm
showing this is what we're looking for
one where our
is on one line in this case one ranked
our queen is on another rank right next
to our King and the enemy King is like
so each occupies a particular line once
we have this type of position this is
where we will next look to improve our
queen position and we could do that with
Queen to d5 notice how the White King is
responsible for watching over these
three squares the White Queen guards
these three and the king is now forced
in the direction we want him to go to
namely this eighth rank so he goes back
we now improve our King position once
more and it's the same procedure over
and over it's the same pattern we once
again have a situation where each
occupies a particular line right next to
each other we now improve our queen
position once more notice because of our
well positioned Queen she's not allowing
the King to go to this square here the
queen is watching over this 'if I've
Square the White King has these two here
he has to go back once more same thing
over and over we improve our King
position again and if black in this
position goes back ever voluntarily we
could look to improve our queen position
immediately if the King goes to e8 in
this position we could basically mimic
that movement play to c7 and he is
exactly where we wanted him from the
beginning the 8th rank but in this
particular example he goes to this g7
square they're each occupying particular
line here particular rank in this case
we can improve our queen position now
and then improve our King position again
and in this final position we actually
have four different ways we can be
giving checkmate any of these three
squares with our queen or even here it
would be checkmate so Queen to d8 is
sufficient enough and that's in black is
in checkmate so just a few positions I
want to show at the end of this video
here to be aware of things you want to
avoid positions you want to avoid
our stalemate of course we're looking to
win this type of an endgame stalemate do
know will only occur if our queen is a
knight's move away from the enemy king
this is this is the only way there is
the possibility to have the enemy King
be in stalemate if we're making a King
move black now has no legal moves and is
not in check this will be a draw just be
aware of these types of positions the
Queen again whenever she is a knight's
move away from the enemy King you could
run the risk of putting your opponent in
stalemate and just a couple more here to
close up King is just a knight's move
away in that situation and lastly
another situation here where again if it
is black to move he would be in
stalemate but again just a very quick
recap what we did here with checkmating
we cut the king of we improve our King
position as best we can and slowly work
as a team with our king and queen
forcing the King to the edge and then
finally giving checkmate so that's all
for this video as always I hope you got
something out of it and I'll catch you
in video 2 take care bye
you